joining me today is a student and
activist and the director of high school
outreach for turning-point USA Calcasieu
welcome to the Rubin report thanks for
having me on I am excited to have you
here we've met a couple times we've done
some events together you are seemingly
wise beyond your years
Thanks that's true yeah all right let's
get to it well actually I mean in a
weird way I guess you've been you've
been sort of thrust into being wise
behind your years you were obviously a
survivor of the Parkland shooting as you
know I had your classmate Chimeran
Caskey I'm a couple weeks ago and he
kind of laid out what happened to him
that day and subsequently everything
that's happened so let's just start
there because that's kind of what put
you on the map okay I'll sort of preface
it um I don't like her I don't like to
refer myself as a survivor because I
wasn't in the building that was shot
into and I think that you know cheapens
knee of pain and tragedy that people who
were in the building so what happened
with me that day I was fourth period I I
was in I was in my fourth period class
and all of a sudden the alarms ring so
we go into the hallway and we're walking
out and we hear two like two little pops
I don't know if two tech books fell you
know fire fire works I really had no
idea so we run back and I go and reach
for the other door to my classroom and
the the teacher locked it so you go into
a nearby room we get in there and we
just hide for two hours straight we just
hear pops and ambulances in the distance
so that was the freshman building and
the entire time we had no idea was going
on and then all throughout the entire
time people immediately are just
villainizing guns you know the second we
got a second I got out of the the closet
that I was in kids were like we have to
ban ar-15s
yeah well let's not jump into the
political part yes it's like because
it's interesting just listening to you
hear about that it's almost like the way
you were describing it almost sounds
like you weren't even there like it's
just like a story that you were telling
you know in a bizarre way so once okay
so all of this happens you find out now
there there are dead students I mean to
do a friend yes old and
so we get it up that we get out of the
closet so woth takes us out they put
their you know err 15s in our faces take
us out we have to put our hands on the
person in front of us walking outside
and all throughout this the most
disgusting thing was every single corner
of the entire block surrounding us was
just filled with media cars
it was just like jam-packed and what I
saw there was that whenever there was
like someone crying or like a moment of
pain the media would just surround them
and encapsulate them and I got home and
I was really hoping that this wouldn't
be like a politicized spectacle with
like mass you know media jumping the gun
to everything and sadly that was the
case so when I was like sitting there in
shock seeing the numbers rise on the
screens for the death count it was like
so insane to internalize like what had
just occurred because like everyone's
always you know this will never happened
to my school how could this happen to my
school and the sad reality is it can
happen to any school like I mean
stoneman's I wasn't the most affluent
low crime you know city I think in like
southern Florida and this happened at
our school did you know some of the kids
that were killed yeah I knew one girl
Helena she was in a class of my year
back yeah so what kind of time did you
guys have to grieve because that you're
already alluding to this but it was like
it was as if the event happened the
shooting happened and then it's
seemingly there was no grieving and then
you guys were all over the television
you were all over Twitter you had all
political people using you guys in all
sorts of different ways just tell me a
little bit about just kind of a grieving
and trying to be able to be how old you
know sanneh 10 you're 17 trying to be 16
15 16 17 year old kids trying to just
survive something unimaginably horrible
yeah I don't know how freshmen and
sophomores like have managed to go
through this like I'm at least in June I
was a junior at the time so I knew the
school a bit better and like somewhat of
my self esteems a little more build up
more and a little bit more mature but
there was absolutely like no time to
grieve or whatsoever like a few days
after the shooting there any buses up to
Tallahassee till you know kind of like
pushed like tugging the emotional
heartstrings of Republicans to pass
legislation that the otherwise wouldn't
have passed who's they in that equation
so there are some members in
Florida Senate that like personally like
coordinated buses from parkland to
Tallahassee yeah and what were your
parents saying or the friends you know
friends parents like it just seemed like
the parents were almost gone now there
are some of the parents that are a
little more high-profile that I that I
see but it was as if you guys were just
like taken that's what it felt like
suddenly we're seeing you on CNN in town
halls and I want to talk a little bit
about that but just like that you were
just used all over the place we're not
even having a moment to just digest what
happened so so here's how I don't think
that necessarily so so here's what I
think would happen I think that the kids
saw what happened they were shocked as
they should be and they decide attack
like we said this can't happen to anyone
else ever again let's do something you
know what really occurred is that the
mainstream media jumped jumped on this
immediately and just like put it to like
a national scale and and really used it
to push a gun control agenda and that's
why I started speaking out because I
wanted to represent the other side of
stone Douglass who doesn't believe in
gun control yeah so just tell me a
little bit about you in high school
before this jump the lie yeah yeah yeah
what was kiled could she like before
this because I know you sort of as a
political beast now and like a wickedly
incisive Twitterer and like you know
you've put on events that I've been part
of and I and you're incredibly organized
and connecting with great people and all
that stuff but just tell me about the
kid before that day I'll give you all
the recap yeah I'll give you the story
of my life life story let's yeah yeah so
so my parents came from Israel they
immigrated here my dad my mom served in
the IDF they came here has nothing
worked their way up and then when I was
when I was at home late Tommy Hebrew in
English so we only spoke Hebrew at home
so I'm fluent Hebrew and they put me
through school and I was always the
shortest kid in the grade so I was like
always like I was just like even shorter
than the shortest girl
am i great I was like super short and
like what was it like like eighth grade
I was four foot eight I was like legally
a [ __ ]
whoa in eighth grade so I got bullied a
lot like I try not to have a victimhood
mentality because I don't think it's
successful and I think you agree with me
on that absolutely so I was always
bullied and I was always extremely smart
so that kind of
back on me a little bit but I was always
bought a lot and it built up my
self-esteem in addition I was always
like taking the hardest classes my
parents would over push me to take the
hardest classes possible so it Douglas
before all this you know I someone had a
good social life so I would basically I
would go to school do my AP classes go
home play video games so like 10:10 p.m.
start homework to like start homework
you know and then finish it at 2:00 a.m.
and then have like 5 hours of sleep
because that was my cycle was terrible
yeah but I was like super addicted to
video games and then the shooting
happens and just turned my entire life
upside down so it just completely
changed me so at that moment you know I
had to become much more mature I had I
was living in the adult world you know I
had responsibilities or things I had to
do you know I had to act a proper
certain way and you know did you have
any particular political beliefs before
all this cuz you're definitely in terms
of at least the the kids or the young
people that are public about all of this
now that have come out of Stoneman
Douglas I mean you definitely are the
one that seemed at least that I know of
is is the furthest right that is sort of
embraced conservatism and all that did
is that where you were politically oh
here's the thing about me my parents
aren't political at all whatsoever so
all my political beliefs I've developed
myself and how I develop every single
political belief is just I look at it
straight from a rational logical point
of view with no emotions whatsoever I
think you can guess I'm not an emotional
person yeah so like I think with with
legislative decisions you have to put
emotion as far out of it as possible you
have to do policies that that actually
solved the problem not just make you
feel good so I'm really not not for like
feel-good policies yeah but did you care
about politics at all before any of this
or is this news yeah I did care the 2016
election I was I was somewhat into it
after the election I kind of didn't care
as much but I was always like somewhat
of a second Amendment supporter yeah but
when I when I started speaking out so
it's really interesting when I started
speaking out ah it was like a tidal wave
of opposition you know I had my schools
against me someone seemed like that you
know all my peers were against me and I
try not to do a victimhood talib it I
just want to paint
sure of how it actually was and then
seemed like the community that
mainstream me and my friends you know it
seems like I was going against every
single opposition you know I was scared
like this could this could ruin my life
but you know I believed in what I was
doing and I just powered through it and
just really I just stuck to my beliefs
in didn't let anyone tell me otherwise
because you know when I was so when I
was in Tallahassee when they were
pushing Republican legislators to enact
gun control legislation
I said look gun control isn't gonna
solve the problem I want to solve the
problem okay I want to make sure that
school school shootings never happened
what can I do to actually make that
happen and what can I do while
protecting the Second Amendment because
I actually believe it's one of those
fundamental rights of Americans so while
I was there I started speaking out and
nobody cared like I would go to
reporters and nobody cared so I had to
forcefully you know like talk to
reporters say hey look I'm a
conservative can I reach out and then I
managed to get Leland Vitter's a contact
with inveterate Fox
and I went on Fox in it in an interview
and then ben shapiro saw it and it blew
off but all the while that's the first
time I remember seeing yeah and all the
while there's this extreme opposition
and the entire thing that I've always
had
sorry wearing it well I just wanted to
what do you because I know you you kind
of mock the media the way I do now on
Twitter and just sort of what mainstream
media has become and that they're really
activists and not journalists and that
whole thing but were you shocked when
you were going up to them and going you
know I'm a conservative or I want to
defend the Second Amendment but I'm a
student from this school and they're
just blue blatantly ignoring you or even
I know this is minor but like I remember
when a bunch of you guys were all
verified on Twitter it was I was like
you worry yeah and it was Instagram as
well it took me like three months after
everyone else yeah and I'm not saying
that that it doesn't really mean it
doesn't matter in of itself
yeah it is it is a symptom of sort of
the broader situation going on here with
tech companies and media and all that
like were they flat-out
ignoring you like you saw them
interviewing people and then so here's
here's what occurred the main organizers
of that that you Sheila Cruz a solid
group of like the March for alive kids
yeah at this point they had solidified a
clique and they wouldn't let anyone new
or with a different opposing view into
it so I said I have to take matters into
my own hand in addition we're in
Tallahassee I realized that the
mainstream media is just doing this for
clicks because can we think about it
when mastering occurs the mainstream
media loves it like they get great
coverage they get great amount of views
they do I'll switch I'll talk to like
notoriety in addition after this but I
saw that when someone there was a girl
crying in Tallahassee and the second she
cried just she got sworn by reporters
and I thought they were just looking for
clicks and for headlines it and I
realized that they're really they're not
reading it for the right reasons they're
not gonna listen to a rational
irrational young kid like me okay yeah
so in addition I also realized that
there was an extreme amount of just
people were just getting benefiting off
of this so much so after the shooting we
realized that a lot of this occurred
because the shooter who I trying to say
his name ever because I think that gives
him to notarize matter they were they
they would they would post so here's
what time did so the video of the
shooter where basically says you know
I'm gonna be the next school shooter of
2018 I want twenty people and he
basically says you're all gonna see me
on the news so and then Time magazine
puts this video up on YouTube it gets
3.6 million views and the same thing
with all the other videos you know CNN
talked about this exact clip and
basically just still showed it on air
yeah so the entire thing what the
mainstream media is doing is that
they're basically they're just
benefiting off the situation and what
they don't realize is they're
perpetuating the issue and making it
worse that's why I think daily wire Ben
is doing a great decision with not
showing their names and faces because
it's an ethical decision yeah no I don't
think government should impose on you
know in the mainstream media to not
allow the show their faces but I think
it's an ethical and moral decision that
people should be taking up yeah so just
to be totally clear so after this
shooting that was when band announced
he's the editor yeah the 1980 wire they
are no longer gonna yet show their name
if they do doctor yeah so okay so you
started to see this this issue with the
media that they're ignoring people like
you and they're sort of making other
people's stars and they're going for the
cliques and all of that
what about you no I don't want to make
this about people per se but so that
that little clique of of kids that then
was all over the media and was getting
retweeted by every celebrity and all of
that were you trying to reach out to
them at all and just have that
discussion or was it just very clear
though yeah absolutely and I still try
to have that discussion you know when
they first started speaking out I said
oh my god that's great someone's
speaking out and originally when the
movement started speed wasn't started
you know remember Cameron kasky was on
the car shouting the movement wasn't an
anti-gun movement it was an anti school
shooting movement and I said hey guys
this is quickly I just I was like I gave
him a warning guys it looks like you're
moving to the direction of an anti-gun
movement and I don't think that's
beneficial at all so here's my point of
view I tried communicating and I and I
tried speaking and they really didn't
care in allowing me so I said okay I
have to go solo and that's what I've
been doing but I've always been open to
discussion and open debate I think I'm
some of the great things of our country
where you can have you know open
discussion and just free expression of
ideas that's why I think the Kayne thing
is somewhat great because regardless of
what you think of the person or
celebrity I'm not I'm not in favor of
propping up celebrities and their
political opinions simply because
they're famous but you don't need a lot
of political expertise to say that I
believe in free expression free thought
right that's that shouldn't be a really
controversial position to be to be
staking out all right so you mentioned
Cameron and you know I had him on the
show okay yeah thanks ago he's going
through a very interesting evolution
right now I suspect I can figure out
where this is gonna end up which
actually be much closer to your position
than the position that he's sort of at
right now because I just continually see
that as the evolution of things the more
that he understands rights and all of
those things but I was happy to hear his
thoughts and all that look he sat down
with me he sat down with Shapiro and I
think he'll continue to do that have you
guys been able to make any peace with
some of this or you must at least be
enjoying the fact that somebody's kind
of coming around you know I think I
think Kim's a good guy I think that what
we're seeing right now is that he's
matured I mean we've all made so Mimi
and cam have gone through like the same
political slash media you know
experience so we can understand each
other
what happened with cam is like look
we've all made mistakes we've
all said stuff we don't want to but he's
matured and I've also matured and what I
see what I think is happening with cam
it's a natural progression of just
having logical thought instead of
emotions and I think logic and facts
moves you towards the political beliefs
of being a conservative okay so all of
this happens I think the the sort of
rock bottom of this was that CNN Town
Hall I was terrible
yeah just share your thoughts on that so
here's what happened with the scene in
Town Hall so a lot of the kids that you
saw there were actually flown in a
private jet from Tallahassee so already
at the time of the Town Hall there was a
solidified group click of the kids that
you see now and they won't let anything
in so they actually flew these kids on a
private jet from Tallahassee to the Town
Hall and right there it was it was just
simply they were just it was an anti-gun
debate and they were just villainizing
Rubio and Dana lash for things that had
nothing into their control whatsoever it
wasn't their fault and Marco Rubio was
villainized to such an extreme extent
and he's one of the best senators so
you've now connected with Rubio
yeah yeah I mean I hate it because when
people say that politicians just don't
care it's just so wrong I mean
politicians they do care and you know he
was one of the greatest supporters of
the stops go violence act that we got
past you just help push it and look
these senators don't want this to occur
Kenney one and just saying that
politicians want this to happen is just
wrong do you have any thoughts on what
actually happened that day in terms of
security or what should have happened or
should have it shouldn't have happened
because even now when you go back and
listen depending on where you're getting
your news from this it sounds you know
they either stepped down or they didn't
go in or this or that or the other thing
and it's like well well what what should
have happened in the ideal world that
that you want to create in the system
that you want to create to protect this
these schools from not having this
happen again what what should happen
that day what we saw my school was
simply and utterly just massive
incompetence and a failure of law
enforcement
so the shooter was flagged multiple
times by the school by the school
administration they knew he had mental
issues he was put into the promise
program and they knew that this kid was
a threat there were 76 times the police
there were 76 times the police came to
his house there were two FBI reports
they knew that this kid was a threat and
the law enforcement was completely
incompetent at that level and they
didn't do absolutely anything
everyone knew this kid was an issue what
happened at school was was just utter
incompetence in addition so when he gets
on campus okay he just makes a straight
beeline for the freshman building and at
the exact same time we had a school
resource officer who heard the gunfire
and came and he just hid in a corner
while kids were dying and then three
unarmed individuals rushed to save it
three are three unarmed went to the
building and died trying to save kids
what we should have had and this is why
I push for it
the only way to stop a shooter who is
active on campus is to have other people
who are armed the only way to stop it's
not a cliche the only way to stop a bad
guy with the gun is a good guy with the
gun and in addition to that there's the
entire idea of a gun-free gun-free zone
it is utterly stupid yeah it is just
completely stupid all it's doing is
enticing a target saying look you go
here so here's here's what's the school
the average response time from police
station to a school nationally it's 15
minutes the average time of school
shooting happens is five minutes that
means the shooter has 15 minutes to do
with whatever he wants if the school is
a gun-free zone so here's what I'm
saying at least allow teachers who have
gone to the proper training you know
ex-military X law enforcement to be
armed because what that does is it sends
not only a message as a deterrent to a
shooter that says look this school is
armed if you get in here your brains are
gonna be blown out it also says that
that the school is in a gun-free in the
school is no longer a gun-free zone so
I'm I'm with you partly on that so what
I would maybe and maybe you can explain
this a little bit further so I don't
know that I want guns in those
classrooms even if
it's so here's the license here's the
nothing fit there are 25 states where
teachers can be armed in our armed in
schools mhm and all the hypotheticals
that are pronounced it's like you know
what if a teacher shoots a student when
there's another like like what if
there's a school shooter and a teacher
gets shot and there's a gun on the floor
what does a student do it's these
hypotheticals don't happen 25 states
where teachers already armed and it
works so why not just have them have
security guards at specific dimensions
here's the thing I'm all for having
security guards this entire issue is how
do we best manage our funds and secure
our schools the thing with law
enforcement officers is that they cost a
lot of money and impoverished schools
already need that funding for materials
and in addition it does not take a lot
of training and a lot of money to have a
teacher to be armed and this has already
been proven to work in an edition when
you have teachers who are armed the
shooter doesn't know who it is if you if
it's a law enforcement officer you can
clearly see who it is so if you've one
resource officer school resource officer
who's armed the shooter comes and takes
out the school resource officer and then
they're free to do whatever yeah but
it's simply so here's the thing simply
giving teachers to have the opportunity
has a massive effect because it's up to
their own will to do so they have to go
through training and they have to it's a
concealed carry so nobody knows they
have them so as you said before you like
facts and logic okay yeah strictly facts
don't care about your feelings all right
I got you that that that works when when
you've engaged some of your friends and
other students about these ideas I mean
everyone watching this at this point
knows that so much of what's coming out
of the modern left is about feelings and
all the other things do you have a sense
that they understand that young people
at least the ones you're talking to
understand like what rights are what why
why we should care about these things
why free speech matters why the Second
Amendment matters and things of that
nature so or does it all just sound good
to them and there's a that's pretty much
it it makes them feel good you know what
they push and makes them feel good by
their emotions that makes sense so
here's the thing I am very scared of
lowering the age for people to vote to
be 15 like that scares me because the
kids that I know who are
tene know absolutely nothing about
politics I think I know like the kids
from a March for our lives better than I
think I know their own arguments better
than they know their own arguments the
guy can argue for them better than they
can do so I strictly use facts only so
when I make an argument with them I
can't really know what they're gonna do
next so here's how I'll give you like a
10 minute or 5 minute Rica tour
basically how I promise the Second
Amendment argument in America we have
the right to bear arms in DC vs. Heller
that right ruled that an individual's
right to arms doesn't mean the militia
the militia Clause is different from the
individual right to bear arms that means
that you personally have the right to
arm yourself okay there are about 270
million guns in United States 15 million
those are ar-15s so we look at the gun
sets or 33 thousand annual gun deaths
sixty-six percent so two-thirds are
suicide so it leaves us with 11,000 gun
deaths so we have so in addition in put
in parentheses there's a different scene
a homicide and a murder
so homicide is just a killing a murder
is an unlawful killing and gun stats a
lot of them like to perverse this into
skew statistics so three percent of all
gun deaths are with rifles okay and in
that three percent 68 percent of those
are suicide so 1% of all gun that's
their actual murders or actually sorry
yeah are actually murders with rifles 80
percent of all gun crime related
activity is with illegal firearms most
schools most shootings are with pistols
so so March for lives has five bullet
points one of them is like I don't talk
about I like to talk about the CDC and
we should allow the CDC to do research
the issue with that is the CDC has
already proven to skew of statistics and
and to not actually provide good
research but what research is it that
they want so the CDC used to be able to
do research on undone violence
prevention and just figure out what's
going on but it's been proven time and
time again that they screw their
statistics so the throne was like no
we're not allowing you to portray a
false myth so a myth so basically they
stopped funding the next thing is that
they want high-capacity magazines there
is no distinction there there is no
difference
that shows that high-capacity magazines
whatever that means you can do more
damage is simply having more like clips
just having smaller just having larger
clips but less of them there's no
distinction that it actually does more
damage the next thing that they want to
do is ban semi-auto rifles as I've said
before only three percent of all gun
deaths are with rifles so it banning
them does absolutely nothing addressing
the issue in lowering gun violence is
making sure that we have Oh making sure
that we have more people who are armed
because there's a direct correlation not
causation but correlation that when we
increase farm ownership and concealed
carry permits in addition violent crime
goes down so the next thing they like to
propose is what about Great Britain and
Australia
so I'm Great Britain there was a there
was a ban on guns it immune ly after
violent crime spiked in addition you
have armed robberies increased so
violent crime increased immediately
after and burglaries in Great Britain
sixty percent of them occur when the
individuals at home versus 30 percent of
the US so burglars have admitted that
they do this because they know that the
person will have like their purse or
whatever and they won't they'll be
unarmed so violent crime spiked the next
thing is they say hey Kyle what about
the Australian gun by program so already
in Australia when the program was
initiated there was already statistical
zero for you know gun death and it's
public mass public school shootings so
in addition when the buyback gets
implemented there already were like
there are millions millions less guns in
Australia than there were now so the gun
buyback grows in only one third of guns
get taken and when we saw immediately
after the buyback was that violent crime
spiked so here's just the basic argument
there has not been one single occurrence
where gun control gets passed and and
and gun deaths no sorry gun homicides
actually decreases at faster rate in
Australia the gun the homicide rate was
already decreasing at a really good rate
it gets passed the gun control and the
rate stalls so it actually hurt by an
addition immediately after it was passed
the violent crime rates go up and the
national trend was going down so the gun
buyback program was completely
ineffective did absolutely nothing and
then it failed on such a huge level in
Australia that implementing it in the US
with George
70 million guns simply won't work all
right so let's shift the discussion a
little bit to the NRA because that was
the other part of this that during the
the town hall and the subsequent
discussions that it got very confused as
to what the NRA actually does what do
they want to do what are the people who
don't like them think they do etc etc so
first up just give me your position on
the NRA generally I think the NRA is a
fantastic organization that defends the
rights the right to bear arms of
individuals thing with the NRA is that
they really don't have the money
influence that people say they do all
they have is the social influence
Republican senators know that the base
believes in the values of the NRA
promotes and defense and they understand
that if they go against the NRA they're
going against their own constituents the
NRA does not have a big budget they
really don't date they're not like this
like super powerful like that they
directly control senators and
congressmen with their money they
control it with their ideals what the
NRA does which is fantastic is it
provides a check from like from the
public not not from the government for
defending our right to bear arms and
it's fantastic you know it helped I
think with the case with McDonald vs
Chicago that helped bolster Second
Amendment rights for individuals I mean
in the NRA does a great job their NRA
ila program which is actually the
legislative branch on defending the
Second Amendment does a fantastic job I
think right now they're taking a case
against raising the age from 18 to 21
there was right for the shooting of Rick
Scott signed into law in Florida raising
the age to buy I think a firearm or a
rifle now so before before you couldn't
buy a handgun if you were under 21 but
you could buy a rifle because handguns
were used in violent crimes whether I
think that's right or not that's a
separate discussion but he raised the
age from 18 21 to buy a rifle and
directly the the NRA was like this is
unconstitutional boom would put in a
lawsuit just to address that 18 to 21
age there is absolutely no evidence that
raising the age does absolutely this
does anything to to lower gun homicide
whatsoever so what do you think about
the certain set of people that think
that if we could just have all
the right laws or if we could just
manage everything properly that
everything would be fine thing is
because he doesn't take into things we
have all the laws that we need already
on the books as thing as the enforcement
doesn't work so I'll just make a tangent
I'll get back to here I think it is
utterly hypocritical that the left hates
Trump and they that he's in power but
then they're saying we have to trust the
government the government if you think
Trump is literally Hitler why are you
giving your way right to Arab arms to
this tyrannical government it was a
question again
well just that there's a certain set of
people that think if we just law I ask
you so we already have the the the laws
on the books you know just the
enforcement is the enforcement of what
needs to occur like the Lautenberg
amendment means that don't
it says that domestic abusers cannot
have a firearm that's ready on the books
it just needs to be enforced there's the
issue with you know the NICs background
check program where they say we need
more time to to evaluate and give you
back your background check in order to
buy a weapon the issue is the government
doesn't need more time it just needs
more of the records so the reason why
the Texas oil and shooting occurred was
because I think it was some military
branch where there was someone who were
he committed a violation and by law they
the heat they should have transferred
that over to the database and therefore
he would have been able to buy a weapon
but the records weren't transferred he
was able to buy a weapon and he shot up
the church so the government just needs
to get all the records and do their job
same thing with red flag laws um and
people like to talk about this this is a
little bit more the trickier areas of
this but red flag laws basically say
that someone can flag you and then you
get reviewed and then you can get your
gun taken away and a lot of people also
like so the issue with red flag gun laws
is that it's all about government
enforcement and and that's that's that's
the issue and there's also the big issue
where people like to talk about mental
health mm-hmm and they say you mentally
ill people shouldn't be able to acquire
weapon so I have talked to countless
individuals about this and I should ask
Peterson but I forgot to the question is
how do you determine when someone is
mentally ill enough and hits the
threshold so they cannot have a weapon
and nobody knows and in addition the
thing with the shooter at my school
looking retro actively we can say this
kid was mentally
saying but I don't know if a court would
have judicata that he would actually be
mentally insane by by law therefore
kicking his gun away yeah so is the
inherent problem here do you think that
you cannot manage all of these things
you can do the best you can to have some
sensible laws around them and defend our
right to bear arms and all of that and
make sure schools are taken care of but
that generally speaking yes there's a
sort of sliding scale psychologically
but also that the people that want to do
bad will find ways to do bad they're not
the ones that are walking out and
looking at a building if it says oh no
guns here yes I'm not gonna walk in with
the gun you criminals will act like
criminals no matter what but the good
thing is that our laws are working I
mean I think it's violent crime or huh
some rate from the 1990s to 2010 has
decreased by 50 percent and and pub and
schools are safer now than they were 20
years ago
like school shooting rates are declining
and homicide rate gun homicide rates are
declining and the homicide rates are
declining so we are becoming a more
peaceful nation and a lot of that has to
do with having more gun owners and to
having more no concealed carry permit
owners because those people when there's
a shooting those people are the first
responders I think it's wrong to say
that oh we'll just let the police arrive
after the crime has been committed no
you need people there immediately to
stop the shooter that's why I'm all for
having teachers and armed school
officers at schools to immediately take
down the shooter all right so let's
shift I mean I don't think we're gonna
fully get away from guns here but let's
shift a little bit okay what is it like
to be a 17 year old right now that's in
the mix of this that's now a public
person do not go crazy yeah to just be a
part of this this oddly unique time
where it feels like the adults have lost
the plot and it's got to be very hard
for you to find people that kind of make
sense I think you've been able to find a
couple of them but just to be 17 in this
very odd political cultural time yeah
it's insane that's it's insane yeah like
what does it feel unique to you I know
you haven't lived through this before
but like the
I don't know how to judge it yeah well
all I know is that I'm an adult now and
I have to act like an adult whether
whether I'm 17 or 18 I have committed
like commitments that I make I have to
go through with them and I've just my
maturity I've like forced to become a
shirt like I can no longer please video
games and waste time there's things that
I have to do but I've just been so
blessed to find a solid group of people
who actually care about me and want the
best for me like like Ben and Charlie
and guy Benson people who have just
reached out to me and him just
selflessly helped me navigate this
political minefield but it's crazy
because like all the people that I
looked looked up to like two years ago
and like would watch their videos not
gonna snack trying like post you go here
but I would watch your show please
continue but yeah it's awesome that now
I can reach out for their expertise the
thing with me is that I always like to
start with look I don't know anything
and I'm always looking to get more
information to know more like today I
had a call with with a gun expert on the
way here and it's like what more can I
learn in order to be like fully fluent
and and in knowledgeable with the
subject that I'm talking about and there
are a bunch of stuff that I don't know
about and I'm constantly trying to learn
so when you see a guy and again I don't
like making this about people rather
than ideas but when you see a guy like
David Hogg out there and he clearly is
taking just the progressive line on this
and he seems more to me to be sort of a
progressive activist than sort of a a
fair arbiter of what's going on here
that's gotta be frustrating for you that
he's so public about this I suppose
someone well that you obviously probably
disagree with him on a hundred percent
of the policy parts this is true yeah I
don't wanna make it about the personal
part but that he's thought of as sort of
a media hero and you're kinda the black
sheep of this group I mean maybe not to
the to the Shapiro's of me and whoever
else so here so here's what I say there
is no issue that kids are on television
the issue is is that when someone is
spouting policy they know they are no
longer a child they are pushing policy
and they should be treated as every
adult is such when you say something
outrageous
should be called out on that I remember
there's a segment with it was on CNN
where he says something completely
outlandish and there was no blowback so
look here's what I think was that the
line about Marco Rubio wants to kill
kids so what I say is when I'm pushing
policy and I say thanks Luke please like
tell me that I'm saying something stupid
and push me back on that the thing is
with me that look when I'm on TV I'm not
talking as a child on pushing policy
right and I expect there to be pushback
I don't think you can say whatever you
want like i and in addition I think that
having debate is great so like I love I
love going on Piers Morgan and having a
debate with that was great mm-hmm and I
think we have to I hate this thing we're
like we're one second you're spouting
policy but then you rush back to the
shield of oh I'm a child but we have to
take my opinion seriously because the
second I say I'm an adult yeah so just
just this isn't this isn't fair yeah and
what I saw I think one of the reasons
why I grew to such publicity was because
I was saying the things that adults
weren't able to say like I was able to
say things that ben shapiro or you or
charlie kirk or the right wasn't able to
say because i'm a kid and i don't think
that's fair because I think that when
you're spouting policy you were no
longer a child you're an adult what do
you make of what's going on with the
right generally because you ran the
turning point was that the high school
event that I did or yes I've done so
many bicycling ups are you okay so you
did the high school Leadership Summit in
DC and I spoke there this a couple
months ago and you had a great lineup of
speakers and peers was there and you had
big big time competitions and and first
up I mean that was the first time we met
and I was like holy yeah we just have
made a mad abortion yeah right okay so
that's my point so first of you you you
ran this whole thing I mean you're
you're you're still in high school right
we're gonna talk a little bit about
where you want to go to college and all
that but you ran an incredible event
with major primetime people and and it
was it was jam-packed and it was diverse
in terms of ideas so we get into a
private debate about abortion but you
brought me there and I went up there
thanks but I went up there and I talked
about my differences with this group I
talked about and it is a respect yeah
and I talked about gay marriage and
abortion and death penalty and a couple
other things that generally these young
conservatives are not for I think gay
marriage they're pretty much for yeah
that the ship has sailed on that one
actually I'm pretty sure I got a huge
ovation on them yeah I think you but it
is just clear to me that there has been
a realignment on the right where there
is exactly what you're so cute yeah can
we just say that Lindsey Graham 2.0 is
fantastic oh the guy it's unbelievable
that I mean just that one the thing with
the tie these great yeah yeah been easy
here's the thing I think the right is
Daily Caller
so I think the right is finally
realizing that youth and like energizing
the youth and instilling the next like
future of conservative leaders is
extremely important and we saw that with
the high school leadership summit we had
some of the biggest name speech like
nikki Haley Betsy DeVos we had like
attorney Jeff Sessions we had so many
people and everything we had Marc
Meadows we did Steve Scalise we had
sweeted we had Prager good you and it
was just it was fantastic to see the
right just understand that these are the
leaders of tomorrow let's inform them
but in addition turning-point is such a
great organization it's free speech free
markets and in capitalism those are the
three Lex ah and what we saw what
Turning Point is such a it's such a
great organization because we were we
brought people who I have disagreements
with to speak there
Mark Cuban spoke got a couple standing
ovations had a debate with Charlie and
people loved it so we're all open having
free discussion and debate like we're
working on sasso shooting action summit
December 19 22nd shameless plug yeah I
think and we're we're looking like how
can we get the most diverse group of
people to speak like I'm thinking about
something from the intellectual dark web
to speak there I think that's great if
we can get Alan Dershowitz just how can
we get diversity of thought so why is it
that this new write or whatever you want
to call it young conservative group
whatever it is why is it that you guys
are able to do this and I see virtually
none of this on your counterparts on the
Left that's not sure I mean the left has
organized and mobilized
you this right now we are well I mean no
no but I'm talking about diversity of
thought like where are they be carrying
their people that's all been mildly
disagree we're not talking about scary
conservatives I'm talking about
old-school liberals where where are they
inviting them to just have an
interesting congressman the left is so
dead set on political correctness and
saying everything to not offend anyone
with the slightest micro micro micro
aggression that it's just you can't live
in that world and and tall it like
logical liberals like yourself are
moving to the right that these subtle
little injections of pleasantry yeah
it's nice are moving people to the right
and conservatives are like come here my
refugees my political refugees we're
embracing you yeah so okay so when I
hear people will say Rubin the
Conservatives are just using you you go
to turning-point they're just using you
you're not just using me Kyle no I mean
yeah but no no but really I mean what
I've seen is intellectual flexibility
there and it's even when I've had been
in here and we've done this conversation
repeatedly about now about gay marriage
I just firmly believe that as time goes
on I can shift him I there's something
that's sort of insulting about it to me
when people say that to me because I'm
confident I'm confident up in my thought
I think he's gonna take you an abortion
I really think that like in a few years
you'll be with us on abortion maybe but
you know what that would be a trade-off
right like if if ultimately I always
describe myself as begrudgingly you know
I think rotor interpretation of of
homosexuality well I don't I don't I
don't have like a strong opinion on it
cuz I haven't thought about it enough by
his religious standpoint it makes sense
but from the government standpoint it
also makes total sense well that's why
I'm completely fine with him it's like
you want to have your religious view I
have to respect that but if you were
trying to legislate my life yeah the
great thing with the right is that we're
open to just diversity of thought just
say whatever you want let's talk about
and let's get to the right rational
viewpoint like I've always been about
debate because it brings people it's all
about logic and it brings people to the
right end result so when I'm on tour
with Peterson the question that I think
both of us get asked more than anything
is what are the best techniques to wake
people up out of this sort of postmodern
identity politics progressive groupthink
as a young person in the midst of this
have what would you say are some
techniques you've been able to use
because it can't just be about drubbing
them with facts right I mean the left is
doing a fantastic job but they're just
craziness pushing people to the right so
it's just sort of standin on themself
what we saw right now with Colleen and
in addition it's just he was simply
saying freedom of expression freedom of
thought I support the president our
president has to be the freshest the
flyest thought why just pushing people
to diversity of thought and freedom of
expression to think whatever you want
you shouldn't have you shouldn't be held
down by your skin color or your race or
you know your sexuality like none of
this matters you should be able to think
what you want and be able to say it
without being tied down by you know your
identity yeah how do you make sure that
you don't get burned out because I think
I remember the first communication we
ever had I think when either you
followed me or I followed you on Twitter
I just sent you a quick one-line note
and I was just like just don't get
burned out because I saw you just you
were in the fight everyday you were you
were owned and owned and the lives and
all that which by the way you know you
mentioned that nikki Haley was at your
summit yeah it's like she went she went
to to you know in effect what is a lot
of Trump people right at this at this
event you put on she goes there and she
says you know don't make this about just
owning the lived yeah and she got
applause for it and I I hit that same
point I think the next day because I
think if you guys do exactly what you
just laid out just kind of stand there
it would be cool and be decent you you
will get decency wins I think I honestly
believe the decency wins can we just
take a second to say that nikki Haley is
fantastic and I I kind of cried for like
a week ever since she said that well do
you think that this is perhaps paving
the road for her running at some point I
don't know there's so many forty chests
like theories I just know I just I know
that she's just been doing a fantastic
job yeah and she's just one of the best
I know nikki Haley Ben Shapiro 2024 yeah
I mean I'd probably have to be press
secretary at that point yeah that would
work for like one horrific week and then
I know that I should
no but all right so give me give me some
of the techniques when you see that it
can't just be about standing still and
fax your if you're in a conversation
with a young person that's really just
bought into all of this what are some of
the techniques you use so that's great
have you been successful
I suspect that yeah sometimes yeah I
think I have the first thing you have to
realize is that is this person looking
tap into open discussion and actually
once sorry about that
talking a lot these days it's alright I
don't too much or actually wants to
develop their point of view if they do
you have to treat it with decency and
respect and not calling them an idiot or
something you have to treat them like a
like a good human being
should and then just have a rational
conversation with them and see where
they're coming from
and a lot of times I I can immediately
know what they're gonna respond to me
like just straight off the bat I know
what they're gonna respond to me and I
hit them with with an initial here's
what's gonna say here's the reason
they're not shocked yeah
but then do you get them around I mean
do you find because it really it's like
sort of deprogramming somebody out of
this and I've had some success at it
right a lot of them watch my show now so
yeah I mean when I first heard speaking
out kids would come up to me in school
and two things they would say be like
Kyle I'm a conservative so the thing
about school was really interesting I
would get stair downs and like people
like like try to beat me up so people
would like send me like hey Kyle watch
out so-and-so it's gonna beat you up I
was like all right man and go for and
people give me stair downs and there was
such a villain ization of being
conservative being second amendments
more when I spoke up I kind of opened
the crack for people to say oh I agree
with him people would walk up to me and
like hushed up like Kyle thank you so
much for doing I'm just scared to speak
out and in addition people say Kyle I
thought I was pro-gun control and you
spoke and I listened to you and then I
did some more research and I agree with
you so that was great to say and like
that's just that's all I'm here for so
then to have people you know understand
conservatism and understand the Second
Amendment it's got to be pretty weird
that you guys are still in high school
right like how you're you're celebrities
in the most strange sense of celebrity
you are and you're all still in high
school together
what is that like I mean at the end the
day we have to remember that were kids
and I will explain it so you guys don't
think I'm hypocritical when you're on TV
and you're spouting politics you're an
adult but in your private life you're a
kid and we cannot forget that so let's
say you know when someone some kid on
the Left does something that's stupid
it's at the end they they're a kid and
we have to address it as such but but
it's it's been a crazy world win and I
think thank God I found a solid group of
people who want the best for me that I
can reach out you know just not for
policy but I've also like personal
advice that guy I out I asked Ben hey
how do you think I should approach
College absence of a conservative you
know and he helped me out and it's just
it's so great to be able to reach out to
people and have them you know give you
advice from like look 20 years older
than me and given me that advice that
they had to go through yeah what was
that great tweet so you're like number
one in your class right not like number
one you are no more nerds yeah correct
there was some tweet that you had about
that I'm awesome yeah what what was that
number one yeah
and people got so angry because so angry
and they're like we're gonna boycott
graduation so I was like yeah more cake
great yeah it was great and then you
know this the next what was the reason
they wanted to boycott good cuz I was
number one right so then the semester
updated and then I was still number one
this I posted another tweet about that
and that also blew up and I was like
we're gonna get Ben Shapiro to come Dana
lash is gonna come yeah it's gonna be
fantastic Chris Cox was like yeah I'm
gonna be there but why would they well I
mean is that really how sort of
polarizing ly crazy this is god yes at a
high school level but just because they
don't like I mean you're number one not
by by it being more deigned no unto you
your number one out of clearly a lot of
hard work and smarts and all that yeah
you'd think that there would be certain
respect for that it's sad that it's sad
that we have we are no longer able to be
friends with people like it's sad that
people in the left think so if people on
the Left think that you're a Republican
therefore you're evil and that's sad
that you're not allowed to be friends
with people who had different political
viewpoints and you're like my best
friend is a liberal and I actually
brought them to the turning point event
and after he was like you know what Kyle
some awesome people made this good pass
I was like yeah I told you yeah what
he's still liberal he's an old-school
label that's cool
he's probably we're getting there you
and him both yeah
all right so wait let's talk a little
bit about college okay so you're you're
doing a great job in high school clearly
now you've got a public profile grades
are great seemingly you could get in to
wherever you want to go and do it yeah
yeah so do you really think that that'll
play a role in the schools that you're
able to get into yeah absolutely
it's sad to say but but there is a bias
against conservatives especially like
the top tier schools like right now I'm
looking to apply to Ivy's I'll be
grating into Harvard or Columbia
I really think man you'd be The
Reckoning of those please I really see
I'd be awesome I really think that I
think it's really important to be
accredited you know I might I've been
thinking about Georgetown or GW to work
on the hill I think that's great
um but you know I really I really don't
know what's next for me I really don't
know it's go to college I'm definitely
gonna stay with turning-point it's a
great organization I'm still gonna be
conservative don't worry we're not gonna
change generally people don't go the
other way right you're not gonna
suddenly grow up and be like nah that's
no no I'll go to the feelings things
that that usually does that won't happen
yeah all right so you want to go to
school but Yuri so you really do think
that your your politics could affect I
guess you know they don't well what
happened with David hog right he didn't
get into to all I don't know what his
grades are but like he didn't get into a
whole bunch of schools right I mean
there have been rumors that he got into
Harvard at Northeastern it wouldn't
surprise me yeah yeah and what do you
want to study he have any idea
it's either business or law I really
don't know yet I just you know I've
always liked like business and I think
law is just absolutely phenomenal I
really don't know yet but you know it's
gonna be great to be in a college campus
where you know everyone is just really
liberal that'll be fun it's sort of
weird and I guess this shows a little
bit about the way the college
experiences is going but in a bizarre
way just knowing
you from a little bit that I know you
it's like in a way it's almost like you
don't have to go to college like I'm
definitely gonna call ya well I'm not
saying you shouldn't and I think there's
all sorts of social reasons that
somebody should go and you can you know
you learn in all sorts of other ways
that aren't necessarily academic but
it's like clearly you've got the
academic thing down and can keep
learning that way so it's all you know
it's bizarre that people spend you know
20 grand a year to go to college when
nobody's I mean the sad thing is we're
surrounded by a lot of great minds is
what I'm saying
I'm with you but the issue with college
is that you're basically paying to get
you're so brainwashed with stupidity and
that's suck part because there were
actually great things to learn in
college just not like lesbian dance
theory like that says that a lot some of
these classes are just useless and you
know and just it's just straight-up
complete stupidity a lot of stuff that
they're teaching there so what do you
make of how this seems to be a through
line through education and I mean high
school education college education
clearly the media like all of the sort
of brain washing stuff that you're
talking about it's always going against
people like you and I see you on Twitter
you you take down CNN all the time you
take down Main Street unity all this
kind of fun people know my thoughts on
this it's like I just wish like to me if
these we just address that Twitter just
Twitter's for fun we have to stop taking
it er so yes so we can your bio your bio
is perfect Twitter is not real life it's
not real life but peep but the weird
thing about that is it's starting to
leak into real life I I did a direct
message like a year and a half ago or so
about how online culture is becoming
mainstream culture and I think that that
really is what's happening here
Twitter's not real life but it's
starting to like leak out into
everyone's conversations on fox news and
CNN and MSNBC are basically Trump's
Twitter like Twitter is like you know
like have you seen shows where they
basically read random replies to
messages it's like John Smith 3.74 this
like that and it is so stupid
but the biggest thing that we're seeing
right now is is a cultural shift with
the youth like memes saying memes have
so much power and are new matter memes
won a lot of memes helped so much for
the Trump's 2016 campaign yeah with it
really did and social media has a huge
influence on our beliefs in our actions
and that's why it is so scary to see
censorship of conservatives online
because that is basically like Twitter
is basically the new version of you just
like yelling into a crowd yeah and
that's basically like the main form of
everyone's communication and shutting
that down it's like heavily restricting
you know I haven't developed my full
opinion on this but it seems as such
restricting this restricts your like
really restricts your First Amendment
right yeah so this is the whole issue
about whether they're publishers or
platforms yeah the big issue I don't
know if saying this right but I think
one of the things if there are certain
if there or if they're published further
than like they have a lot of legal
liability if they're a platform then
everyone should say whatever they want
but that's not the case so it's like
pick one yeah and they're just
completely censoring conservatives like
I know Prager you gets like their videos
demonetised so much and have your videos
gotten to you monetize they probably
yeah well like now it's gotten a little
bit better but our videos just don't go
out to feeds anymore I went on that
career they don't have none of them yeah
that crazy rampage I went on where I
just started retweeting real people I
only did it with real people with real
name saying they've been unsubscribed
and they're getting hundreds and
sometimes thousands of retweets and I'm
tagging YouTube and they just ignore me
yeah and it's like come on guys yeah I
mean Google Facebook and Twitter all
have proven biases proven yeah how
worried are well so it's only
interesting to me because you you never
you didn't grow up in a time when there
was some sort of trustworthy seemingly
trustworthy level of the media like CNN
was not always this the reason I don't
even know if you know this but the the
reason I think that so many people like
me that are older than you
attack CNN the most is COO CNN used to
be decent like MSNBC saying we lean left
yes yeah and CNN saying that and it's
like no you're not
we know exactly what you're doing and
that's why I always tack CNN because
it's like you guys have actually become
the worst in the name
have you seen the ratings are like Oh
everything's all I've ever liked the
lowest it's like a block of red CNN yeah
so here's what I think I think that a
lot of young people and like make an
average Americans do not trust the media
anymore and they have sought out
individuals instead so they trust
individuals so they look to you they
look to Ben they they look to Guy Benson
you know charlie Kirk for for their news
because they trust the individual right
do you see a great risk in that too
because I'm worried about that I also
but but the thing is what that is that
you have absolute liability for what you
say you know CNN can come whip something
up or you know but when when an
individual like tweets something it's on
like they're responsible for their
actions yeah so one of the things I've
been saying lately is that I'm actually
in a bizarre way less interested in
politics now than I've ever been but I'm
interested in what you referenced a
little while ago this culture thing I
mean culture and where's that cultures
politics is downstream from culture yeah
that's so true yeah so do you see that
really as as sort of the future of all
this that it's not going to be about all
of the little machinations of politics
it's just going to be about I mean this
I guess this is the strength of Trump
well you'd argue it's either the
strength or the the the worst part of
Trump I suppose that he's a cold but
yeah he's a cultural thing not
necessarily a political thing no I mean
they're pros and cons to that but we
just we have to play by the rules that
are set by society and these are the
rules these are the rules that culture
has a massive impact on society and
whether I like it or not that Kanye is a
Kanye speaking out first of all I think
it's great to be speaking out to the
First Amendment right I don't think we
should be propping up opinions by
celebrity symptom because they're famous
you have to show that you are informed
on the subject and that's that but it
doesn't take a political genius to say
that I believe in our Second Amendment
in our First Amendment that doesn't take
but Taylor Swift doing like a 7,000 page
write essay you know that makes
absolutely no sense and contradicts
itself written by like a liberal you
know worker on the hill that I was
disappointed in that just because I have
no particular feelings about her won I
don't care
and why I don't think I could name one
song or whatever but it's just like the
fact that she stayed out of politics I
liked I was like oh whatever she's doing
or whatever her handlers are saying to
her I kind of like it and then she got
in on this and it's like I don't care
which way she was gonna break I was just
like ah we just this is not what we need
yeah I mean a Taylor Swift effect
president is like down Marsha Blackburn
love so thanks Taylor Swift yeah no but
but what we saw right now by the left is
that they are losing their stranglehold
on culture and that is very frightening
for them and we saw that with Kanye when
Kanye started speaking out I gave my
speech about this and they started off
with mob tactics that didn't work
emotional appeal the TMZ guy was
basically begging him on Kanye please
men take take off your hat man it hurts
me emotionally it was like no it's my
first time owner I'm not taking it off
and then we saw just blatant racism yeah
Viola character assassinations and so
that's custom not that that is how does
that fly he wouldn't bow down to the mob
absolutely wouldn't but but no they're
losing their stranglehold on culture and
whether I like that we are putting so
much emphasis on my cultural icon those
are the rules
them the rules like they say don't put
her a lot but this is this is this is
the reality that we're living in and we
have to understand that and what's
happening with Kanye is a real shift
especially for african-americans and
people who are like in little Tino's
they're basically saying I don't know
why this controversial blacks don't have
to be Democrats you don't own me
basically it's all he's saying and he is
created such a like a pivotal moment
that says you you're you don't your
stranglehold doesn't affect me because I
know in Hollywood like the second you
say something like I remember someone
said Ben Shapiro is a nice guy his
career was destroyed a mark Duplass
who's a friend of mine he's been on this
show and he had to issue an apology and
it's like you know oddly what is the
world the idea of people people came to
his defense at first basically saying
you know you should be allowed to say
that yeah and then unfortunately he is
black and black especially young blacks
are saying look they look up to Kanye
West
they millions look up to him and they
say this individual why does this
individual think this way and even more
so he didn't bow down to the mob which
is fantastic and we're seeing like a
real shift I don't know the 38 percent
number were 38 percent african-american
boomer Trump I don't know if that's
necessarily true all I know is that
there was a three percent jump from
there was in August the black approval
rating of Trump was three percent one of
the latest polls that I know a month ago
was 10 percent so there's a big jump you
know we're seeing that so many young
african-americans are so energized like
I know turning-point is doing a black
Leadership Summit like a week in the
White House mm-hmm
we're gonna get just 400
african-american young individuals to be
able to speak there since our table
listen and to see that the left is
losing their stranglehold on culture and
it is scary for them because that is the
one thing that they have left all right
I got two more for you
all right you are you in the prediction
game at all what he thinks gonna happen
in these midterms we got coming up so
what I've been hearing is that
Republicans don't lose it in the house
and gain in the Senate I love how I'll
cause your work as is that we're gonna
win back the executive these minute
sounds very confused better clothes
yeah but look the cabin effect is real
yeah like this was like the all the left
had to do was sit down be quiet be civil
play nice to like no no this is we're
not gonna allow this okay and they hid
themselves in a foot with the club and
then there started crying
and then the same thing with Kanye that
was great so the Kavanagh really amped
up and energized the conservative base
and even more so it finally gave the
conservative like the Conservatives a
backbone like we're in a game Lindsey
Graham 2.0 yeah where is this guy bid
yeah I love it
and like Bill Cassidy's but but here's
it appears the interesting thing women
were the most angered by all of this
before the Kavanagh in August it was
like thirty five point seven percent
approval of Trump after was a forty
point seven and before in August the
Democrats had a 12 point lead over
Republicans in a voter enthusiasm now
it's 64 percent Republicans 65 Democrats
so we are neck and neck in this
it's all thanks to Democrats yeah I mean
my gut as long as you're doing
predictions here I actually think the
Republicans are to do well in both the
House and the Senate I really hope so
really but I do think so because I agree
I think this mob mentality and watching
these videos of antia and Portland and
Hillary saying we can't be civil and
Eric Holder saying
megalo leak them and it's like man if
you stand for due process and civil
society and all of those things that
thing needs to burn it kind of sucks but
it's like that that set of ideas the
left thinks the left just completely
disregards the Constitution the
Constitution was written and and like
the amendments Bill of Rights was forced
by anti-federalists to make sure that
the government could not become
tyrannical and abuse its power and this
is so important it's protecting the
rights of the individuals and these
rights why why do we not all agree on
them why is it wrong to believe nude
process why is it wrong to say I believe
that individual should have the right to
defend themselves and also defend
against the tyranny of a possible
government look second men was basically
written because the founders had just
fought against Great Britain and they
had seen how a tyrannical government
quickly becomes so one more thing I
didn't know the first thing tyrannical
governments do is they take away the
weapons of the civilians so this a Nazi
Germany we saw this in China we saw this
in in Cambodia that's the first thing
they do and the individual right to bear
arms is every individual it's not
related to the militia clause so it's
basically saying every individual is the
right to protect themselves and even
more so it's it's necessary for the
protection of a free State all right one
more for you hit me wait you don't play
video games as well I don't because you
don't have time what do you do for fun
man what's fun I used two sides Twitter
you can't just tell me Twitter I know
you haven't put on Twitter but it can't
just be Twitter what are you doing for
fun so with me I used to play a lot of
video game game so here's here's my
progression I haven't said this but this
is like a scoop World of Tanks
okay it then moved to to rocket League
okay it's suck it's terrible game it's
boring then it moved too so I played
overwatch I played paladin's I played
pub G and then I played for night and
for nine this was when all the shooting
occurred and I just stopped dead in my
tracks because it was just it's a waste
of time
and I see my younger brothers who are
addicted to the game and it's just sad
to see that this is the state of our
youth that they're just completely
addicted to technology like I'm sure if
I have kids okay they're not saying a
phone till they're twelve you know they
do is to call me or 9-1-1 that's it no
video games you're reading a book I
don't care so what do you do for fun you
just like you told me what you used to
do huh come on you must be having fun
somewhere you're having fun sometime
Wow I got you yeah man yeah no but
you're you are having fun with this yeah
some of the remaining friends that I
have which were really solid friends you
know in weekends we hang out we go watch
movies and stuff like that in addition I
just think it's great one of the
greatest things for me for having fun is
just simply talking to like-minded kids
like young individuals at these
turning-point events that we run and
it's great I like meeting with in
pushing policy and stuff like that it's
just fantastic like one of the greatest
feelings ever was like passing the stop
school violence act and fix Nick's like
the stop squats act appropriated funds
to billion dollars in funds for the
protection of schools like hardening
schools metal detectors making better
communication to the law enforcement
training law enforcement teachers and
students in addition there was a clause
that said none of this money will be
used for firearm or firearm trainings
so this was like the greatest win for
the left and they still hated the bill
and like a much more alive kids hated it
but no I mean I'm really dead set on
making sure that school shootings just
are thing of the past they never happen
again and you love what you do is just
like just learning about Second
Amendment and just like being more
knowledgeable and having these debates
and discussions or just like they really
make my day yeah well I think it goes
without saying I mean I think you have
an absurdly bright future thank you like
you're gonna run for president or saying
probably not no no yeah but you left a
little window yeah no I mean I little
window maybe there's a thing for
politics like the hill in the future
right now I'm dead set going to college
getting my degree learning ah staying
the political sphere but uh you know who
knows I'm definitely supporting nikki
Haley Shapiro 2024 dot all right you see
people there is hope for the future for
more
ronk I'll follow them on Twitter at Kyle
cashews
[Music]